-You look great.
You look like a million bucks.
You don't look tired, and
I would have thought you did,
because you went on a
vacation with your family.
-Yes. Yes, I did.
-And you have
a couple of older kids
and you've got a 10-month-old.
-I do, yes.
-And you took your 10-month-old
to the Bahamas.
How was your first trip
with a 10-month-old?
-You know what? It was great.
-Okay, good.
-I got a good 10-month-old.
-Yeah.
-He's, like, a 10-month-old,
but he's like 30.
-Oh, that's good.
-Yeah, he's very, very relaxed.
Like, he's extremely mature.
He can chill.
He can just watch TV.
But he'll change and
just look at you for a while.
There's sometimes where you
got to pluck him,
make sure he alive.
-Yeah, right.
That's the one downside of
a chill baby, yeah.
-"Hey, man,
are you breathing, man?"
He'll just sit with
his mouth open.
But he's amazing, man.
I love him.
-Here you are with your family,
and I want to --
First of all,
I should note you went --
There's a pig --
A beach that has pigs on it.
-Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
Pig island.
-Pig island.
-Pig island, yes.
-So, there you are
with some pigs, but --
And that's fascinating,
but what's more fascinating --
is it fair to say
that your entire family
is wearing the same
patterned swimsuit?
-100%. 100%.
-Okay.
Gotcha. And was that
an accident or on purpose?
-No, it's because I'm black.
That's what we do.
Black people --
we like to match.
It's a thing.
We go overboard with matching.
I am that dad.
-Congratulations on
"Night School."
This is a really funny film.
And this is based,
on some degree,
on your own experiences, yeah?
-Yes, 100%.
It's based on second chances.
That's what the whole purpose
behind the movie is.
You know, I think so many people
frown on second chances.
You know, when you don't get
something right the first time,
ultimately, you're down
and you feel like,
"I'm not going to do it.
I'm going to go
in another direction.
It's over."
Well, this is a movie
that shows that it's okay
to go back the second time
and give it your all
and take the things that you
didn't do right the first time,
apply it to that second time,
and come out better.
And, sometimes, it takes a third
and fourth time, you know?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's what this is about.
So, I'm a victim
of not getting it right
the first time
for a lot of things.
-You've got a great cast --
Tiffany Haddish, Taran Killam.
-Yes.
-You also -- I know, in the prep
for this, you got to --
You were a principal
for a day in Dallas.
-Yes, I was. Yes.
-You gave sort of a TED Talk
of sorts to kids in Atlanta.
-Yeah.
-What do you try to
impart upon students?
-Well, the first thing is rules.
You know, when I got to be
principal for a day,
I felt it was very important to
make my presence felt.
You know, I'm a big fan of
Joe Clark on "Lean On Me."
-Uh-huh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah, yeah. That's right.
Those are the people that know.
-Some Joe Clark fans.
-That's right -- Joe Clark.
He's the real deal.
"You smoke crack, don't you?"
That's one of the best lines.
But I said, you know,
I wanted to change some things.
So the first thing I did was --
I said, "We're going to
have chicken nuggets every day."
-Yeah, that's good.
No one's going to fight
you on that.
-I like nuggets.
That was a great rule.
I took all the
toilet paper out the bathrooms,
replaced it with baby wipes,
and said, "It's important that
we all wipe our asses properly."
-Okay.
-You now,
that's something I did.
-Especially after, like,
nuggets every day.
-Yeah, after nuggets,
you're going to need it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. You get it.
You get where I'm going.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-And I was on a roll, and
then the real principal came,
and he was like,
"This has to stop."
-Yeah.
-He took my bullhorn away.
And then I gave,
actually, a real speech
and I told the kids --
I said, "It's very important
to embrace this moment
and really understand
what teachers are."
I now, at the age of 39,
understand the importance
and value behind these teachers.
You know, teachers are
investing time, energy
into these kids because
they feel like the kids
are our next generation's
leaders and groundbreakers.
And I said,
"Your biggest reward to them is
by doing something
with your life.
Take advantage of this time
and really apply yourself."
[ Cheers and applause ]
And, you know, it was good.
It was good because
they related, they responded.
They identified with
what I was saying,
because it was coming from me.
-It's a fantastic message
to give them.
I also -- Another
thing that's interesting is --
you know, I think people look at
you and they think, "Oh, my God.
You're so successful."
Everything you do is successful,
but you have also had films
that did not particularly work.
You were in a film,
"Soul Plane."
"Soul Plane" was not
a huge box-office success.
-Yeah.
-But you have a theory
as to what went wrong here,
and your theory is based on --
-Well, it got bootlegged.
My movie was bootlegged
before it came out.
Do you know the background
of "Soul Plane"?
-I don't know.
-Oh, let me educate you.
So, "Soul Plane"...
"Soul Plane" was supposed
to be the one.
That was going to
take me out of here.
-Yeah.
-Oh, my God.
It's about to go down, okay?
-Uh-huh.
-This is -- Here it comes.
Somebody give me
the money train,
'cause after this movie,
it's going to happen.
-Gotcha.
-I'm at the airport.
We're still
filming the movie, actually.
We're doing reshoots.
And a guy comes up to me.
He's like, "Oh, my God.
You're the guy from
'Soul Plane.'"
And I'm like,
"Hey, how you doing, man?"
He's like,
"Man, the movie's funny."
And I was like,
"Well, you're going to
really think
it's funny when it come out."
He's like, "No, it's out.
I saw it."
And I was like, "No, you didn't.
You couldn't have seen it,
because we're still shooting it.
We're actually shooting
it right now."
He was like, "No, I saw it.
I could tell you everything that
happened in the movie."
And he starts telling me all
the scenes in the movie.
He was like, "Dude, would you
mind signing it for me?"
And I said, "Signing what?"
And he pulls
the bootleg out of his bag
and he's like, "Sign it."
And I had no choice.
I had to sign it,
'cause it's the first autograph
I've ever really given.
-Yeah.
-So I was excited.
And I immediately,
like, called the director
and I was like, "Hey, man,
a guy just told me
he had the bootleg."
And he's like, "No. No way."
Before we knew it,
in like a month,
I was the biggest thing
on the streets.
Everybody had this movie,
and the movie --
the date that it was
supposed to come out,
we had to push it up
like a month
because they was like,
"We got to just get it out."
So we were trying to lie.
We were like,
"There's new scenes
that you haven't seen
in the bootleg."
It's was like,
"Oh, you think you've seen it.
Well, wait till
you see the new stuff."
-So your release
was effectively like,
"We're re-releasing
'Soul Plane.'
-We had to re-release based off
the bootleg.
We were like, "We know
you think you know the end,
but look at what we just added."
So we're, like,
cutting together trailers
that aren't even in the movie.
It's, like, me fighting
somebody in karate,
like, "Aah, aah!"
It was like,
"Wait till you see this
new action scene in
'Soul Plane.'"
And the movie ended up being
the biggest hit on the streets
but one of the biggest flops
in the box office.
But there is a positive
in every negative.
The positive is --
that's how the following
for me in comedy started.
I was able to
go to comedy clubs,
and they were like,
"That's the guy."
-Yeah.
-I was, "That's the guy from
'Soul Plane'" for a long time.
-Hey, thanks so much
for being here.